I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense well tell the pontoon boat story
so everybody asked me they're like how
did you start out in racing and I always
tell them my version of it which it's
better if you tell the version and I'll
tell you if it was any different from
what I say but it's a kind of a fun
serendipitous story I'm trying to recall
it all exactly it'll be it'll be close
basically I was um ice help old buddy
mine racecars because I had racecars
dirt midgets and I couldn't afford it
anymore so I hoped good friend of mine
Joe Corrigan and one week he got really
busted up and he probably shouldn't race
again he had all tore up so as if one
were his eyes were black eyes were black
and blue yeah last ray is kidney and all
kinds of stuff pancreas didn't work so I
said Joe why don't we just buy a pontoon
boat rather than going racing every
weekend you know I'm thinking well just
cruise around drink beer and a boat it's
a lot of fun so we looked at Bolton and
it didn't happen and um so it's like to
stay busy in the weekends what I didn't
we decided late let's try go-karts
because the one babysitter would race
him mm-hmm Theresa yeah Theresa - in
Milan yeah
and Brooke went to school Brooke was in
the same grade as Theresa's sister yes
sister can't remember her name but yeah
and they lived in the neighborhood right
okay so they stay race go-karts - and
brooke says you know cuz she was you
know she slept with the Joe Corrigan
shirt and all that and she goes I want
to race so we said all right let's try
go-karts I'll take one day off a week
and Sundays and we'll go racing go-karts
who is the braver of the two of us
growing up Rooker me a good question I
don't know I don't know if there's a
brave difference you were both very
repetitive you wear the same clothes the
same shirt same dress you were a dress
every day mm-hmm I'm girly that's what I
tell people about me they're like Lord
what do you think what surprised me
about you that I don't know and I'm like
that I'm kind of girly yeah
Burke was probably more than tomboy okay
because I don't feel very brave but yet
Brooke wanted a race and I just didn't
want to get left out that's how I
remember it
yeah you said you'd try it I said I'd
try it you'd say you tried yeah so we
know you know so we bought two go-karts
a night right that's a similar story I
mean my story was that you wanted some
my service that you wanted to spend more
time with Brooke and I because you
worked so you were gonna get a pontoon
boat but instead it was a little less
about joke or getting a little bit more
getting high in the love yeah but you
know it's okay it's probably part of the
story yeah and and then you you know
instead of so the pontoon boat started
we didn't buy a pontoon boat why did we
buy go-karts dad so I get by we I mean
you
so you take one day off we can spend
with you kids know why we didn't buy a
pontoon boat no we didn't why I didn't
know enough about a murder this is a
critical part of the story I don't think
I looked that hard to be honest I
thought it was amazing this story dad
well here's the story let me tell you
how you need to tell it moving forward
because it's better that you called
somebody about a pontoon boat and they
never called back okay did that mm I
don't think so [ __ ]
if you say it did it happen how's that I
can tell why you've been married for
almost 40 years yeah I had a white flag
I'd be throwing up in the air like a
[ __ ] flag too so no you didn't ever
called it by one I don't know I don't
remember doing so I may have I don't
know I'm old did mom mom she was no
bookkeeper she wouldn't call them and
you're right mom's not very
confrontational
she wouldn't know wanted to make that
phone call so unless it was about
getting paid she calls about that yeah
[Music]